today on the matte wall show jesse
smilet's attacker has been sentenced to
jail time but the sentence was still too
light i think as uh smollett's insane
behavior in the courtroom demonstrated
we'll talk about that also our big tech
overlords have gotten together and
decided that it's actually okay for you
to call for the murder of certain people
depending on their nationality and
ethnicity nothing troubling about that
at all plus kaepernick compared the nfl
to slavery a few a few months ago and
now he says he still wants to play in
the nfl he wants to be a slave i guess
and rihanna is pregnant and speaking
eloquently about the beauty of pregnancy
and the preciousness of her unborn life
which which seems to contradict her
previous
uh pro-abortion activism this is a
pretty common thing with pro-abortion
celebrities we'll talk about that and a
new poll says that americans are under
an unprecedented level of stress is that
true are we more stressed out than
anyone in history is life that hard or
do we just see it that way we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
well the ever increasing numbers of car
makes and models it's now impossible to
stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront so why
should you endure the pointless and
always uh seemingly intimidating
questions about the specifications of
your vehicle only to have the guy behind
the counter order the parts on his
computer anyway
you have computers with access to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil and even
new carpet whether it's for your classic
or your daily driver get everything you
need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the rockauto.com
catalog is unique very easy to navigate
you can see everything that you need
right away and best thing is you you
know it's it's very affordable why spend
up to twice as much
for the same parts why spend twice as
much for a worse selection doesn't make
any sense go to rockauto.com amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now and see all the parts available for
your car truck and remember to write
walsh in their how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you
so last night the years-long saga of
jessie smallette finally reached its
exciting conclusion i feel a certain
sadness the same bittersweet feeling you
know the experience after watching the
last episode of a great television
series um and this has been a great
television series in its own right
certainly the most compelling thing that
smollette has ever starred in
um although his performance i think
still needs a little bit of work uh you
know the story of smellette's hate crime
hoax it really has almost everything
that you you could want a story it's got
comedy it's got drama it's got action
the action's a little bit too
choreographed and also not that
convincing there's no romance which is
probably for the best unless you
counselette going to a gay bath house
with his fake attackers before the
attack
that's a subplot that we can hopefully
leave out of the film adaptation
although who am i kidding hollywood is
going to turn that into a 45-minute
sequence sequence in any case all of
this culminated last night at smilet's
sentencing hearing now cook county judge
james lynn
listened as smallett's defense team
presented the testimonies of a whole
parade of of character witness the whole
witness is a whole litany of people all
attesting to the fact that smollett is
kind and generous he's got a great heart
he has an undying concern for social
justice
and the interesting thing is that
tactics seem to backfire big time when
it was time for judge lin to finally
render the sentence
because the judge noted how
smallet's alleged activism and his
alleged charitable endeavors only make
his hypocrisy even worse because if he's
really so concerned with racial justice
then he would of all people know
what sort of damage this hate hoax would
do so lynn pointed out that this only
underscores smollett's arrogance
narcissism his callous disregard for the
harm that he would cause
um the judge explained all this in an
extremely long monologue where he went
back over the entire case offered his
reflections and analysis
probably more detail than any of us
needed but the good thing is that we it
was all the more embarrassing force
millet to have to sit there and listen
to it
all over again
now before getting to the sentence
my one qualm with lynn is the judge is
how he focused so intently on the way
that smollettes hoax would as he said
denigrate and degrade real hate crime
victims for him that's the main point
right that's the that's why this is so
bad he said that hate crimes are the
worst thing anyone can do and it was
sick and twisted for smollett to exploit
them for the for attention the way that
he did
now yeah it's true that it was sick and
twisted no doubt about that
um it's true that hate crime hoaxes like
false rape claims do have the effect of
discrediting real victims and that's a
serious problem and that's something you
have to weigh as well
but it's not true that a hate crime is
the worst thing a person can do okay i
would say that crimes against children
are the worst thing
it's also not true that the denigration
of hate crime victims is the most
salient aspect of this case
what the judge didn't mention
what almost nobody mentions
is that this hate crime hoax was itself
a hate crime this was a crime targeting
white people if any group is the real
victim that's it i mean he was for his
own selfish reasons trying to inflame
hatred against whites he was furthering
the false media narrative that white
racists are patrolling the streets even
in chicago
and attacking and trying to kill black
people
if that seems like a stretch or
something to just imagine if a white
actor
had made up a story about um two
stereotypical black men assaulting him
and yelling die whitey or something in
the middle of the night
if that were to happen everyone would
agree that this is that the hoax itself
is anti-black and racist there would be
no disagreement
on that point well the same logic
applies here now it's somewhat amazing
that nobody not the prosecutors not the
judge
nobody has mentioned the fact
that if two white people had happened to
be anywhere in the vicinity and had
ended up getting blamed for this fake
crime
smilet would have absolutely let them
take the fall
and spend decades on in prison on
federal hate crime charges
now of course it was very unlikely
that two white people would be like
hanging around chicago at that time of
night just walking around and end up
getting um pinned for this
we know that that's unlikely that's what
made the whole story ridiculous
but smolette didn't think it was
ridiculous
he thought he'd get away with it so for
him anyway it was it was at least
possible
that two white people would be hanging
out outside
now you don't stage a fake hate crime
unless you are prepared to let a fake
culprit do the time for it
and in fact it's why it's significant
that he said that the culprits were
wearing masks
which means
that he wouldn't be able to tell if you
know if if
if two people end up getting
um end up getting fingered for this
thing and the cops go to smollette and
say are these the guys
well smilet wouldn't be able to say oh
no it's not them because he didn't know
what they looked like
so he had specifically set it up
so that if two people innocent people
end up getting pinned for this crime
there's nothing he'd be able to do about
it a hate crime hoax is like throwing a
grenade into a room you know knowing not
knowing if there's anybody inside or not
maybe you think it's empty maybe it's
not somebody might get hit with a
shrapnel you may not have been
intentionally targeting that specific
person but you know that someone might
get hit and you did it anyway
that's the worst thing about this crime
and nobody involved in the case pointed
out that out
that's because all of them are beholden
to the leftist racial narrative which
says that non-white people are always
the primary victims of everything even
of hate crime hoaxes perpetrated by
non-white people
now of course as it happens smileth
throws like a girl so the grenade only
made it about three feet and then rolled
back in his direction and he blew
himself up instead but his intentions
were the point
so with all this factored together
it was kind of hard to predict
what the sentence would be from the
judge what sentence would he pass down
and then uh the time arrived let's let's
listen to the moment
i'm fashioning the following sentence
and here's your sentence i'm sentencing
you to 30 months fellaini probation and
the probation is going to be to this
court
you're going to be allowed to travel
wherever you want you do not have to
live in the state of illinois
you can report by phone i know that if
you're going to try to make a living and
do some of the things you do you may
have to go to
other other places in new york and los
angeles you can do those things
you will pay restitution to the city of
chicago in the amount of one hundred
twenty thousand one hundred six dollars
you are fined
twenty five thousand dollars which is
the maximum fine
and you will spend
the first 150 days of your sentence in
the cook county jail and that will start
today right here right now
i do appreciate how he he saved the jail
time for the end because millet thought
because he he went right and said oh
well you're going to have a probation 30
months ovation whatever it was and so
smellet was thinking oh thank god and at
the very end so yeah by the way you're
going to jail for the next six months
right now um so i appreciate that that
was a lot of fun
but probation first of all is
meaningless because he can still go and
travel and do whatever he wants um a
small fine minor restitution you know
for him that's that's not a lot 150 days
in jail um some people are calling this
a
stiff sentence or a harsh sentence but
the judge admitted before giving the
sentence that the law technically
allowed for three years in prison on
each conviction he was convicted of five
charges
which means he could have got 15 years
in prison
now the fact that he has and he should
have he should have gotten 15 years in
prison the fact that he has no remorse
whatsoever as we'll see in a minute no
remorse
um the the plus the extensive
premeditation that went into it the
callous disregard the fact that he was
prepared to send innocent people to jail
including his friends by the way that's
the other thing the friends that he that
he
roped into this thing is patsy's
after they turned against him
then smallett's narrative changed and
said oh yeah well they they attacked me
but i didn't tell them to so he was
ready to send them to prison for this
even though he's the one who got them to
do it
so the fact that he was going to send
people to jail now the brothers aren't
exactly innocent but um
still
the fact that he was trying to cause
more racial tension in the country along
with the fact that um hate crime hoaxes
are an epidemic and somebody needs to be
made an example of if we're going to
stop this
all of this warrants the maximum penalty
as far as i'm concerned a few months in
jail is about the minimum that could
possibly be justified and so smallet got
the minimum he got the bare minimum of
what you could possibly expect
and here is how he thanked the judge for
it listen
and i am not suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there i did not do it to
myself and you must all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
now this man cannot stop acting and he's
so bad at it too which is the problem
he's in court a convicted felon going to
jail and he's still putting on a
performance
like he thinks this is this really is a
tv show
obviously the point of the whole i'm not
suicidal thing was to suggest that
there's some kind of conspiracy against
him he might be killed in jail
uh no one's gonna kill you they're just
gonna laugh at you you dummy
in fact this guy is he's such a
damned attention seeking narcissist that
i wouldn't be surprised if he actually
does hurt himself in jail he might even
kill himself just so that he can you
know still be the victim in the end
but the reaction from some light was
interesting because you can tell
that he's a man who has never been held
accountable for anything in his entire
life he's a man completely absorbed in
himself in his own sense of entitlement
he's a spoiled rotten child
never faced any consequences for
anything
the fact that he must now face a real
consequence even though it's a much
lighter consequence that he would what
he should face
is just it's incomprehensible to him the
greatest part of that diatribe was at
the end where smollett scoffs and says
jail time jailed him and he's speechless
at the thought well yeah jesse you you
were convicted of five felonies did you
really think that there would be no jail
time at all
he did think that because he's been
coddled his whole life
why should it stop now he thought
smilet really in many ways i think is
the perfect mascot for our culture for
this generation i think that's the
lesson we could take away at the end of
all of this at the end of all things at
the end of all things jesse that's what
we could take away from it it's what
makes this story relevant actually
we know what makes it hilarious and it
is but it's relevant because smallett
is the prototypical product
and representative of modern american
culture a self-entitled phony
performative pampered hypocrite who has
lived such a comfortable and luxurious
life that he's developed a fetish for
oppression it is a fetish for him
he's been given everything in life
except he's beginning everything you
could possibly want except for a genuine
opportunity to be a victim that's the
one thing he was not given that's the
one gift that life never gave him and so
he went seeking it out
and when he couldn't find it he created
it for himself if you want to hate crime
against yourself done right do it
yourself he thought
except he can't do anything right
because he has no skills or talents or
abilities or intelligence of any kind
and so he botched it and made a fool of
himself
the whole story is so quintessentially
modern and western
he should replace the bald eagle as our
national mascot because he's the sort of
man that our culture produces
when you think about it like that
the story isn't quite as funny anymore
though it's still pretty funny let's be
honest now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
all right so the daily wire is creating
a universe of woke free entertainment
just for you that means that we have
your weekend entertainment covered uh
this weekend every weekend especially
this weekend our latest movie the
hyperions debuted last night on our dw
premiere event uh the hyperions is a
film unlike any you've ever seen and
that's why we love it it's a highly
artistic fantastically fun movie about a
dysfunctional hero family with a
decidedly retro vibe the hyperions won't
lecture you with predictable woke
characters and cliched storylines it's
just pure entertainment the way movies
should be speaking of our movies you got
to see shut in the daily wire's first
original film it's a riveting story
about redemption currently has an
audience score of 96 percent on rotten
tomatoes
and you can watch the hyperions and shut
in right now also coming soon we've got
a lot of things um coming down the way
gina carano will be starring in daily
wire summer blockbuster terror on the
prairie really looking forward to that
and and speaking of must-see weekend
entertainment sunday ben will be sitting
down with the one and only bill maher
for his sunday special show it's bill
maher unleashed uncensored and um
there'll be no censorship or apologies
there as always
newsweek even uh wrote up the interview
quoting bill
saying my politics haven't changed
they've changed and uh so you don't want
to miss that also you don't want to miss
our documentaries like china the enemy
within a gripping five-part series from
the creator of the plot against the
president uh lee smith rhymes did i
mention our one-of-a-kind shows like
third thursday book club candace
debunked the search
and this is where you come in okay we've
got all this stuff if you want to take
part in this then we need your
membership your membership makes all of
this possible by the way when you join
the daily wire not only do you get great
movies great documentaries original
shows awesome content you also get our
investigative journalism that fearlessly
goes wherever the story does so
all this stuff suffices to say is great
reason to become a member and if you
want to do that go to dailywire.com
watch today help us build a universe of
news and entertainment that reflects
your values again go to dailywire.com
watch today
well
i think we should start with this i mean
this to me seems like
a big deal you you may recall
how i've pointed out a couple of times
uh there's a contradiction here bit of
hypocrisy
in the way that we are
you think about uh
asian people after the china virus
spread throughout the globe and killed
five million people or uh muslims after
9 11 and how this was this intense focus
in our country and making sure
that people who had nothing to do with
it are not um are not are not subject to
hate of any kind uh because of it so
there was this real focus on we don't
you know islamophobia we don't want to
be islamophobic we don't want to have
anti-asian hatred and all of that
and then
russia invades ukraine and all of that
sort of goes out the window and now it's
open season on russians literally now
okay so this is this is the report from
reuters
it says meta platforms which is the now
the parent company of facebook will
allow facebook and instagram users in
some countries to call for violence
against russian soldiers and russians
okay not just the soldiers in the
context of the ukraine invasion
according to internal emails seen by
reuters on thursday and a temporary
change to its hate speech policies the
social media company is also temporarily
allowing some posts that call for the
death of president vladimir putin or
belarusian president alexander
lukashenko in countries including russia
ukraine and poland according to a series
of internal emails to its content
moderator so
uh depending you can call for the deaths
of certain people depending on where you
live this is all geographically based so
if you live in these certain countries
then you are allowed to want these
individuals to die um if you live
outside that country then you can't of
course any other individuals you can't
want them to die but but these specific
individuals you're allowed to we're
going to put that into the hate speech
policy now
these calls for the leader's debts will
be allowed
unless they contain other targets or
have two indicators of credibility such
as the location or method one he has
said
what in a recent change to the company's
rules on violence and incitement okay so
if you live in these particular areas
you can call you can call for these
particular people to die um and
it can be there can be one indicator of
credibility
but not two
so you could say like
for example um
hey uh
vladimir putin is
in this particular location someone
should go kill him
but you can't say vladimir putin is in a
particular location somebody should go
shoot him okay because then you've got
location and method so you want to be
more
uh circumspect about one of those things
or you could say i hope or rather
someone should go poison
putin's breakfast
and you can say that
as long as you don't say where they
should poison the breakfast like you
don't say oh next time he's at denny's
they should do it just be be general
about that part of it this is the policy
now
the email said calls for violence
against russians are allowed
when the post is talking about the
invasion of ukraine they said the calls
for violence against russian soldiers
were allowed because this was being used
as a proxy for the russian military and
said it would not apply to prisoners of
war
um the temporary policy changes on calls
for violence to russian soldiers
apply to and then there's a whole host
of eastern european countries that
you're allowed to do this
and um many major social media platforms
have announced new content restrictions
around the conflict so and so forth so
there are new uh restrictions
because we want to make sure we don't
have any of that russian propaganda
now ukrainian propaganda of which
there's been plenty that of course is
allowed so we allow certain types of
propaganda and not other kinds and you
could call for the deaths of certain
people but not others
it it should um it should freak you out
that
social media
platforms people running these platforms
all they all had to sit think about
imagine being a fly on the wall
in this meeting they had to sit down and
have a meeting about this this was at
some point they actually sat in a room
there were individuals sitting in a room
talking about
the policies for who you're allowed to
want to kill
and they sat around and agreed to this
it should freak you out that our big
tech oligarchs our big tech overlords
are now putting themselves in the
position of deciding
you know who is worthy of death and who
is worthy of life
and of course again this will this would
this would never apply in any other
circuit the only reason why this is
being allowed is because russians are
perceived as white even though a great
many of them really are not
but they're perceived that way and so
that's why this is allowed
um would you be allowed to
call for the death of um
you know any
uh
anyone in the chinese government of
course not you wouldn't
because they're they're not white
all right ron desantis
once again is uh putting on a clinic for
us and for other republicans showing how
it's done
um this is like episode 500 of ron
desantis showing how it's done so this
but
this is this is worth really thinking
about and looking at because
um it's very rare that we see this from
republicans in fact we've seen
republicans many times many examples
especially governors and especially in
the last you know several months
caving
immediately
because of pressure from the left and
especially pressure from corporations
and especially
corporations in their own states
that donate money to them in their
campaigns and whose business you know um
you know the powerful corporations in
their own state
most republicans are not especially
republican governors are not able to
withstand that kind of pressure
now ron desantis on the other hand
has disney the most powerful corporation
in his state
and one of the most powerful
corporations in the entire world putting
pressure on him because of this
so-called don't say gay bill
and it's called that because of all the
propaganda and lies being told about it
and he has refused to cave so here he is
uh this is a video from fox
talking again about this and just
showing once again showing republicans
how they should handle these situations
let's listen to some of this
so here's what i can tell you uh in the
state of florida
we are not going to allow them to inject
transgenderism into kindergarten
first graders shouldn't have woke gender
ideology imposed in their curriculums
and that is what we're standing for
because we're standing for the kids and
we're standing for the parents uh and i
can tell you this
there the chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights simply because of
fraudulent media narratives or pressure
from woke corporations the chances of
that are zero
when you have companies that have made a
fortune off being family friendly and
catering to families and young kids you
know they should understand
that parents of young kids do not want
this injected into their kids
kindergarten classroom uh they do not
want their first graders to go and get
told i'm glad you got to that that's
another good point about disney that is
not appropriate right for those of you
so there's there's ron desantis that's
something another good point about
disney is that they are
they produce
content for children and now they have
come out so strongly in favor of
sexually grooming children
and so if you let your children
um consume content from disney that
might be something worth thinking about
in the future of course we should have
been thinking about it before because
disney has been crazy leftist for a long
time
um but that's that's ron santos i mean
he's
i i'll i'll keep on saying it until it
until it manifests and becomes reality
but
he's he's got to be the guy i mean we're
it's crazy
to consider anybody else at this point
there's just there's just nobody else
who's on his level
um and that
of course includes trump ron desantis
what you saw there that's that's he's
got all of the the upside of trump and
none of the downside
the only thing that trump has that
sanders doesn't have is all the name
recognition of course trump is one of
the most famous people in the world and
he was even before he ran for president
so desantis doesn't have that to that
extent
but if he's the guy and and he's the
republican nominee then he's going to
get a lot of that
name recognition
so that's that's that's a problem you
can solve but when it comes to qualities
as a politician it comes to that like
what he brings to the table in terms of
his skill
um he's got anything trump has and um
and there's a lot of downside that trump
has that he doesn't have
um and he's also able to
which i think is really important
you know using the bully pulpit
as they say
being able to talk about these issues
in um you know you don't have to be
shakespeare
and ron desantis isn't he he comes off
like a basically a normal guy
and that's that's good actually
but he's able to talk about these issues
in a in a coherent way
like he can focus
you get the sense that you could sit
down from across the table from ron to
santos and talk about an issue
um for 30 minutes
and he could stay on topic and and talk
about it and offer some insight
you know whereas with trump it's it's
all over the place he's he's not able to
stay on message at all about anything
and um you just don't you don't get the
sense that he quite
is quite as engaged with these issues or
cares about them
um the same way that you do with ron
desantis all right
adam schefter over at espn reports
he's got he tweeted out a little video
of colin kaepernick
out on the football field kaepernick
tweeted it saying still working and then
uh schefter says colin kaepernick is
still working out and is said to be in
the words of one source in the best
shape of his life he wants to play he's
ready to play he would be a great fit
for teams with qb vacancies to fill uh
who want to win a super bowl
now this is it's always been the case
that most of the people pushing the uh
kaepernick narrative i mean shafter
works for espn but a lot of the people a
lot of people in the peanut gallery
pushing this narrative and the ones the
ones who are still saying yeah why does
someone give kaepernick a shot a lot of
them have no idea don't know anything
about football don't follow it have no
clue whatsoever um and you would have to
know nothing about football at all to
believe any part of that to believe
first of all that he's in the best shape
of his life
at 34 years old
and he hasn't played in what six seven
years and he's in the best football
shape of his life at 34.
almost nobody is in the best even the
people that have star quarterbacks have
been in the league this entire time
it's it's very rare that someone is in
the best shape of their life at 34. like
tom brady is one example he was in the
best shape of his life for like 10 years
um
but 34 is where the drop-off happens
and sometimes very steep drop-off for
almost all even the even the star
quarterbacks who have been playing this
whole time
so the the idea this guy could come in
at 34 hasn't played
his last time in a league he was a bench
warmer riding the bench behind blaine
gabbert and he went like one in 10 with
the san francisco 49ers
the idea he could come in six or seven
years later and win a super bowl is
absurd and everybody knows about
football knows that uh the other absurd
thing is the claim that he wants to play
because here's the here's the dirty
little secret about colin kaepernick
which is not much of a secret at all um
he doesn't want to play at all he
doesn't actually want to play that was
clear a couple years ago when the nfl
actually held a workout for him
specifically in the middle of the season
which they never do for anybody
and um and he boycotted the workout
because there wasn't enough media there
and then held his own and then he spent
the entire workout work out railing
against the nfl and calling him a bunch
of racists like this is not someone who
wants to play for the nfl also
if you wanted to play football he could
be playing football right now you've
been playing this entire time
there are other professional football
leagues out there
that they don't have the same
star power or or or you know they're not
people don't care about them the same
way they do about the nfl but if you're
if you're out of the nfl for any reason
and you want to get back in and you want
to play football then you just go play
for another league and you show people
that you can still do it not with an
eight-second video of you running around
the
football field by yourself throwing a
football
so he could be playing he doesn't want
to play
and
that's really
like the best case scenario for him is
that it's a lie that he wants that he
wants to play he's actually just a con
man and this is all part of the khan of
course
because then you'd have to think well if
he does really want to play what does
that say about him considering the fact
that he just did a netflix special
where he compared the nfl to uh slavery
and said that nfl owners are slave
owners
and now and how he wants to he wants to
was he wants to be a slave
you guys are a bunch of racist slave
owners can i please work for you
what does that say about him
so no matter how you cut it and how you
slice it um this guy is a fraud and a
con man if you're still buying into this
then i think there's just no no hope for
you
um
[Music]
all right let's go here rihanna
big music star is
it shows you how plugged into the
culture i am that i can tell you that
about rhiannon she's a big musical star
rihanna and she's also pregnant so
congratulations to her it's very
exciting
here she is on some red carpet somewhere
talking about her pregnancy listen
i do feel very beautiful it's from
inside you know like all these changes
that your body are going through
is for
you're creating this person like a life
like yeah and and even when i'm reading
like all the apps i don't find out what
my body is doing and what the baby's
doing this week yeah it freaks me out
like god really does not make a mistake
everything is for a reason i'm enjoying
it and i'm appreciating everything
uh god does not everything she said
there of course i agree with quite
profound actually um and it's a and you
would like to say it's a wonderful thing
to have uh women who have this kind of
cultural credibility uh and a lot of
legions of younger fans
when they're pregnant and they're proud
of it and they're out there talking
about god she says god doesn't make
mistakes she's referring to the child in
her womb as a life you know it's a
precious beautiful life
all that is really great and wonderful
but it raises some questions like for
instance a couple years ago
here she is tweeting about a law in
alabama which restricted abortion and
here's what she said about that
she said
uh
take a look these are the idiots making
decisions for women in america governor
k ivy shame on you so
rihanna was very upset about a law
restricting abortion she's a
pro-abortion she's a pro-born she's an
outspoken pro-abortion activist
and that's what she has been up till now
and now she's saying god doesn't make
mistakes and it is a life in the womb
now how can you possibly how do these
two things fit together
i mean if you're saying god doesn't make
mistakes which he doesn't
then that means that and you're saying
that the unborn child is a life then
then that means that every child
who is conceived
is a human life
that god has sent here to earth and he
didn't make mistakes so you can't say
anything about it as an accident or is a
this is unwanted this is a
child who's not supposed to live you
can't say that
the god wants
all of these children to live that's why
he created the life in the womb of the
mother in this miraculous
moment of conception
how can you how can all these things fit
together i mean how can you think that
but also be in favor of abortion
because now you if you're if you if you
hold all of these views in your mind all
at once then that would mean you know
it's not that you have convinced
yourself that the unborn child is a
meaningless clump of cells but that
would mean that you actually
know that this is a human being a
precious
human being created by god and yet you
still are in favor of killing 60 million
of them since roe v wade
even worse
so it seems like a like a contradiction
and uh hypocrisy and you know in a
certain way it is but a certain way it's
not actually
because the view
held by rihanna um
and all of these celebrity you know
these left leftist celebrity women who
get pregnant and uh they decide they
want to be pregnant thankfully and uh
you know they taught they say all these
wonderful things about pregnancy yet
they're pro-abortion the view that they
all hold the view held by rihanna
is that her baby has worth
um because
it's her baby and she wants it
so it's everything she's saying that
doesn't she does not mean that to apply
to all children no no no
this this is my child and i'm rihanna so
and i want this child
and so because it's me
and and because i have a desire to have
this child that means that the child now
has worth and is a is a life given to us
by god
so really it all comes back to me
um and this is something that the left
been if you listen to them they've been
pretty open about this in fact
there was a famous i think was someone
on msnbc a few years ago said that you
know life begins whenever the mom wants
the life to begin that's how they see it
it's actually not about god at all
the woman is god
and you can decide through your own
desires your own emotions
whether that life has worth or not
it's worth this contingent upon how
desirable
the life is to you as the mother
that's how she sees it speaking of
twisted and perverse that's that's how
she sees it all right one other quick
thing i i have to i just i have to play
this for you i can't i can't not play it
um tess holliday is a plus size
model
is how she self-identifies
and she also has recently we've i i
think we mentioned this before a few
months ago when the news came out that
tess holliday who weighed you know she
weighs
i
by the looks of it she weighs 350 plus
pounds and but she's she has she's
anorexic she says and so she was on a
talk show this week
talking about her
her battle with anorexia
um and here she is talking a little bit
about about overcoming and the courage
it took her to overcome anorexia listen
to
this
i
i feel immense gratitude and pride that
i am able to sit here with you and talk
about such hard things and know that
there's somebody on the other side that
feels less alone that maybe says to
themself i'm gonna get help asks for
help
starts taking care of themselves in the
way that they deserve because
you know plus size or not we all
everybody deserves food everybody
deserves to eat
you know
i
we deserve to take care of ourselves we
deserve to live without judgment we do
we do yes that's the biggest thing in
all of it are you currently in therapy
how often are you yeah so um i see my
dietitian once a week and then i have my
therapist once a week
and i have a lot of people in my life
who lovingly just
nudge me nudge me along the right path
and
yeah i'm
doing it
she sees her dietitian once a week
uh might want to ask for a refund on
that
i mean in some ways you know it's it's
inspiring i think to see someone
who has so thoroughly beaten anorexia i
mean she has
dominated
and crushed her anorexia
um
this is a this is like mike tyson in his
prime
okay
that's how that's how much is a first
round knockout of anorexia
um
man
now look everything she's talking about
she she's uh
she says that you know uh talking about
eating disorders and people and she it's
okay to ask for help
all of that is all that's of course true
and um it is also true that you could
say that she has an eating disorder in
the sense that
she's eating way way too much in in
quite a disordered way in fact in a
self-destructive way
but that's not what she means okay
she actually she's claiming to have
anorexia
which by definition anorexia is you know
with
not eating
you know keeping yourself away from food
to the extent that it actually causes
you to be you know famished
where you're like starving yourself
that's what anorexia is
and i yeah you can't judge a book by its
cover but i am pretty sure that test
holiday is not starving
all right
i'm just gonna stop while i'm ahead
let's get to the comment section
they're the sweet baby gang
all right uh dailywire.com baby comments
let's play clip 11.
hey matt uh
i'm at work sitting in my car here
kind of
memories of the old days
anyways i wanted to ask a hypothetical
question
that as a christian do you think
it is morally justified
to have a desire or thoughts or
you know a want to
physically handle these
sexual predators people who are hurting
children yourself like wanting to
take care of the problem yourself
um
do you think that is morally justified
i
i have uh family members that seem to
think that
it's um
wrong when people
you know
like there's that recent case about the
ufc fighter or whatever that hurt hurt
the guy that touched his kid
um
what do you think do you think that that
could be a godly and righteous anger
inside of a person a justified action
uh or do you
you know what what do you think sweet
baby king for life
uh yeah
so is it is it is it uh godly or is it
right does christian have violent anger
towards
sex predators i think i think probably
part of the reason you're asking asking
that question is we talked yesterday
about
you know the case at the at the dunkin
donuts where the customer was berating
the ducky donuts employee and uh
screaming at him called him a racial
slur uh and he got punched in the head
and then he ended up dying and i
mentioned how
it turns out not that the doug duns
employee would have known this
necessarily but
that this guy uh vanello cook i think
was the name was a sex predator and
child molester um and so that means that
uh
putting everything else about the case
aside like i don't care that he's dead
it doesn't doesn't make make me sad that
he's dead because that's how i feel
about people who um who harm kids
so anyway
now so is that all consistent with being
a christian to feel that way and i would
say absolutely yes
um
the whole idea that that we as
christians are never supposed to be
angry about anything that that that
concept just doesn't
hold up
um
upon any
deeper reading of the scripture or not
even deep reading just pick up scripture
and read it like any new testament old
testament just just flip flip open the
book sometime
and uh read a few pages and you're
almost certain especially in the old
testament but in the new testament also
you're almost certain to be given
examples of righteous anger um which is
which in fact is like all over the old
testament the the the bible including
again in the new testament i mean jesus
is shows anger
um
on several occasions and not just
the you know famous case of of clearing
the temple which in that case he
fashioned a whip i mean he used physical
violence
and not in self-defense you know it
wasn't physical self-defense he wasn't
being attacked physically
but he used violence
himself
and
and then there's many other cases of
showing anger so there's nothing there's
nothing in and of itself wrong with with
being angry
um i think the question is what do you
do with that anger and also what why are
you angry so if it's personal resentment
personal grudges
that's not good anger that's not that's
not holy righteous anger
um if it's your own pride that's been
hurt or damaged
that's that's not righteous anger if
it's
just irritation that you're allowing to
get out of control you're flipping out
because you're stuck in traffic and
you're angry at everybody maybe there's
a traffic jam and
for all you know there's the traffic
jams because there's an accident a mile
up and someone's dead and all you're
thinking about is yourself and you're
getting angry none of that stuff is
righteous but
the anger that you feel towards someone
who harms children why do you feel anger
because that that anger is rooted in
your love for the victims
it's the same anger that i feel when i
think about um abortion the anger i have
towards abortionists it's the anger i
have towards uh these
these quacks who
chemically castrate children
mutilate kids gender confused kids i
feel intense anger towards them
because
it's not they're not doing it to me
right like you're not talking about
someone who is who's preyed upon you
it's because of what they're doing to
innocent people
it's an anger
that is that is grounded in love it
springs from love and so yes love can
lead to anger
in fact i go farther than that i would
say that um
if you don't feel angry if you do not
experience intense anger
um
when someone is being victimized then
you don't love that person
all right
good question though um let's go to
robert he says i've read the story of
sodom and gomorrah a few times and have
pondered how in the world a couple of
large populations got to the point of
mass sexual gratification hysteria now
the pieces are beginning to fall into
place
um we're becoming ripe for destruction
kind of fits in with what we were just
talking about couldn't agree more
zachary says matt i disagree with you on
the dunkin donuts story if the employee
punched the guy for yelling and
disrespecting him that would be one
thing but punching him because of a
single word that's pretty pathetic
well i'm not sure that you disagree
because that's
basically what i said i mean the problem
i have with the sentence the guy got
house arrest when he punched a guy and
killed him
you know the issue i have with that
sentence
is that it it wasn't because
the vanilla cook this the child molester
was screaming and carrying on and
everything else wasn't that generally
was because of that one specific word
and so the precedent that you're setting
in the court system
is that if someone says a word one
particular word one magical word then
you could kill them
so that was that was my it was my take
on it
so i think i don't know how much we
disagree uh there was one other
thing about the dunkin donuts okay ethan
says honestly i bet matt has never been
in a fight why else would he feel not
only comfortable but justified in
hitting someone who says something he
doesn't like sounds like a totalitarian
response
spg dude but you have a ridiculous take
on this fight story if you could call it
a fight more like a cowardly cheap shot
okay ethan first of all not a cheap shot
cheap shot is when you run up to someone
you know and you and you surprise them
out of nowhere and punch them it's not a
cheap shot
when your fate when you're squaring off
with a guy and look at him in the face
and especially in this case the dunkin
donuts employee warned him said said you
know get out of he was warned
and the trial molester kept kept going
so
you're you're squaring off you're
looking him dead in the face you've
warned him like i'm gonna hit you if you
don't back away then you hit them it's
whatever else you call that you cannot
call it a cheap shot
um
but yes and and also by the way you say
it's a totalitarian response well i am a
theoretical fascist dictator so you
shouldn't be surprised by that
uh but also
what so so you're you're claiming that
there's there's never an occasion where
it's appropriate to hit someone unless
they hit you first
i just don't know where we get that and
why is that treated as if it's
self-evident and i don't even think that
you believe that i mean let me just give
an example ethan i don't know if you're
married but what if you were out in
public and somebody came up and was uh
sexually harassing your wife
doesn't doesn't touch her okay but it's
like sexually harassing your wife and
you're sitting right there
are you gonna go up and excuse me sir
will you please leave i
sir
i do not preach sorry i need you to
leave okay i do not appreciate this if i
if you don't mind me saying in fact
i'm a little bit peeved in the way
you're treating my wife but no if you're
if you're a man you're going to walk up
to that guy and punch him in the face
because that's what he deserves
that is behavior that warrants violence
i didn't say you're gonna pull out a gun
and shoot him
okay not all violence is the same there
are there are gradations here
so your response has to be proportional
but that is a proportionate response
that is someone are they a victim i mean
the way they're behaving are you really
going to say they're a victim they
didn't have it coming they didn't bring
it on themselves
and yeah putting everything about racial
slurs and everything else aside
when you go in
and start screaming at someone getting
in their face and cussing them out
because you're upset that service has
taken too long
and you're getting their faces screaming
adam um yeah you you brought that on
yourself you deserve to get punched
and that's why i said if you if you're
in a physical state
where getting punched might kill you or
one if you're so fragile that one punch
of the head might kill you then maybe
watch your stupid mouth
there's an idea
okay
let's get to the daily cancellation
[Music]
well a new survey from the american
psychiatric association has led to some
dramatic and startling headlines nbc
news reports that americans are besieged
by stress and the hill says that we are
experiencing alarming levels of stress
then there are the headlines from
nbc and yahoo
claiming that we poor souls in america
today are afflicted by unprecedented
levels of stress yahoo reports quote
financial woes coupled with a barrage of
horrifying scenes from ukraine or as
russia continues its invasion have
pushed the majority of americans to
unprecedented levels of stress according
to a new report from the american
psychological association the
association's annual stress in america
poll published thursday found that the
us adults already weary from two years
of covet 19 are now overwhelmingly
troubled by inflation and the war in
ukraine according to the results 87 of
those surveyed cited rising costs of
everyday items such as groceries and gas
as a significant source of stress the
same high percentage said that their
mental health was greatly affected by
what was by what has felt like a
constant stream of crises without a
break over the last two years 94 said
that the russian invasion of ukraine is
terrifying to watch
now
um i don't mean to get into semantics
here but i think it's worth pointing out
a couple things and one is that our
stress in modern times is certainly not
in any way historical or unprecedented
americans have lived through
actual world wars
pandemics also we've lived through that
many times and many of those pandemics
have have especially afflicted children
as opposed to kovid which especially
spared our children thank god
you want to talk about stress how about
hop in a time machine go back to a 19 to
let's say 1862.
ask americans back then about the
stresses of living through a civil war
where six hundred thousand americans
died two percent of the population the
equivalent of losing seven million
people today in a war can you imagine
that a civil war
seven million men are killed in in if
you if you look at it in proportion two
percent
um
so you want stress try that or try
living out on the frontier out in
comanche country in the 1840s
or being a subsistence farmer during a
drought
or really try living in any time period
before modern times back when you
actually had to try to survive and you
were surrounded by death all the time
and the child mortality rate was
exponentially higher than it is now and
women died during childbirth all the
time
you know if you were if you were a
60 year old man with
eight kids if you if you live that long
it's almost certain that you've you know
you've had two or three wives by now
because the other ones die you've
probably had two or three kids who have
died um literally every aspect of life
was significantly harder and more
grueling than it is for us today now as
i said not it's not semantics but when
we start talking about unprecedented
stress i think it's important to
remember
that history did not begin last week
perspective is what we're missing and i
think our lack of perspective is one of
the things that contributes to our
stress
you know we really think that like
everything we go through every every
little thing we we
every little or big thing that we go
through we think it's well this is the
worst thing ever this is the worst thing
that's ever happened to anybody
and it can be helpful to realize that
nothing we're going through is new um
people have been experiencing and
surviving in spite of all of these sorts
of things all through history there has
never been a time of utopian peace and
tranquility
that sort of existence is simply not on
offer it's not available to us it's not
in the catalog right
of uh of when you're a mortal human
being life has never been easy
the life that we're given right now is
as close to easy as humanity has ever
gotten
and we can't stop complaining about it
so what does that tell you now
i don't mean to dismiss all the sources
of stress mentioned in the poll
certainly inflation high gas prices that
causes stress and you can't afford to
put gas in your car and go to work uh
when it's financially back-breaking
simply to fill your shopping cart at the
grocery store you're gonna feel stressed
about that and rightfully so that's not
a small stress either that's a big
stress
um and when we're being led by feckless
incompetents who cannot fix these
problems and don't seem particularly
interested in fixing them that's only
going to add to the stress as well
but should we be under intense stress
because of ukraine
you know 80 of americans said that
they're living in terror because of
russia's war in ukraine
are they really
i find it hard to believe because i have
not met one single person in real life
who appears to be terrified by what's
happening 5 000 miles away
but if they are is that kind of
emotional reaction justified
is it proportional to the risk that they
actually personally face
the same thing with kovid which which
has been another big stressor as the
poll indicates
certainly many of the things the
government did in response to covid
caused stress shutting down schools not
to mention the whole economy is a stress
inducer yeah
but the virus itself was not a fatal
threat to most healthy people
people were certainly more stressed by
that than they ought to have been as all
of the outdoor mask wearing indicated
and still indicates you know i'm in dc
this week and there there are still
people walking around you know walking
their dogs jogging while double masked
alone outside
so where does all this stress come from
if we're so historically stressed out is
it because our lives are historically
difficult or is it something else
and i'm thinking it's something else to
something else's specifically one
our problem is that we don't know what
to pay attention to this is this is a
big problem in america this is a crisis
level problem
a problem of attention
our attentional priorities are entirely
out of balance and in disarray that is
something that is unprecedented it's
never been this bad when it comes to
attention not being able to pay
attention to things and it's not because
we all have some mysterious mental
illness like adhd it's just the way that
our culture is it's the world that we're
living in
uh not being able to pay attention to
important things not knowing where to to
put your attention you have so many
different competing claims on your
attention
americans spend an average of seven or
eight hours a day staring at screens now
this fact alone would seem to contradict
the claim that our lives are
unprecedentedly difficult and stressful
most people in history would not have
had the luxury to spend the majority of
their waking hours sitting around and
staring at screens
if they had any screens to stare at to
begin with but the point about the
screens is that our digital diet means
that we're constantly having our
attention directed towards whatever
stressful thing the media and big tech
companies want us to think about for
whatever reason
so our minds and souls are bombarded
constantly every day with a barrage of
information and misinformation and
events and propaganda and everything
else which have the effect of blotting
out from our minds
the things that are actually closest to
us as we are immersed in these things
that we cannot control and don't
understand
and which often have little relevance to
our actual lives
this is how people ended up end up
stressed out by something happening a
million miles away only to forget about
that same thing a week later
so they can become overwhelmingly
stressed out by something else that
they'll then forget about
the internet is a stress machine in that
way
but many of the stresses are
essentially phantoms
two finally the other thing contributing
to our stress is that we're so
obsessively focused
on our own stress
we think about our stress all the time
we talk about it we like to tell people
we like to say to people i'm so stressed
out i'm so busy here's what's happening
in my life we go around telling people
how stressed out we are
you know i said earlier that you should
go back in time in a time machine and
ask somebody in 1862 about their
stresses but actually you can't do that
because first of all you probably don't
have a time machine but also because the
people in 1862 wouldn't have known what
you were talking about stress is a
modern invention
prior to the 20th century nobody talked
about their stress they didn't have that
concept
to say you know to ask a person if
they're stressed they would have looked
at you like what does that even mean
that doesn't mean that they didn't
experience stress as we think of stress
it just means that they didn't use the
word
or or think of things in that way
which meant that they certainly weren't
intensely intensely focused on the
subject like we are today
in fact the entire category of mental
health
would seem totally foreign and bizarre
to pre-modern people
that's not to say that stress and mental
health don't exist or are myths or
something rather it's just to point out
how we've gone all the way to the other
extreme end of the spectrum
we are consumed by the thought of our
own stress and our own mental health we
are stuck inside our heads constantly
analyzing how we feel and how we feel
about how we feel and how we feel about
how we feel about how we feel this only
exacerbates the anxiety and the stress
it's a self-perpetuating cycle
that's why perhaps the best thing to do
sometimes i think
and this is a good good thing as we head
into the week
turn off the screen put down the phone
um go out and get some exercise
pick up a hobby
do something i mean engage in some kind
of actual physical activity
in the three-dimensional physical world
and think about something else literally
anything else
aside from yourself and and your
feelings
that's the other advantage that
pre-modern people had
which which probably um
you know gave them better mental health
in the long run though they you know um
that they didn't have that category they
didn't think of it that way and their
lives were much more difficult still
they lived in the world right they lived
in the physical world for better or
worse they inhabited the spaces where
they lived they actually inhabited they
were they concerned they concerned
themselves with what and who was closest
to them
and spent most of their time thinking
about those things
so we should try that for a change
it'll do wonders for your stress and
your mental health
maybe something to do over the weekend
and since since i'm supposed to cancel
something at the end of the segment i
guess um i guess i'll i guess i'm going
to cancel our modern obsession with
stress that's what's canceled today and
we'll leave it there for today and the
weekend
and talk to you next week godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin